es ist die schlimmste
infektionskrankheit der welt und kaum
einer hat sie als diese auf dem schirm
tuberkulose experten vergleichen sie mit
der hiv infektion mit aids klicks um
science-fiction
ja es ist wirklich die schlimmste
infektionskrankheit der welt zitat
tuberkulose hat heute ungefähr den
stellenwert den aids in den 80er jahren
hatte eine krankheit die sich über die
luft verbreitet und an der man stärken
kann
dieses zitat ist keine panikmache denn
eric orie ist nicht irgendjemand er es
sondergesandter der vereinten nationen
jeden tag verlieren mehr als 4000
menschen weltweit ihr leben aufgrund
einer tuberkulose infektion
jährlich kommen über neun millionen
weitere erkrankte dazu damit sind aber
vermutlich noch lange nicht alle
infizierten bzw erkrankten auf gezählt
und das trotz der meldepflicht schon bei
einem tuberkulose verdacht müssen ärzte
ihrer meldepflicht nachkommen wie auch
bei vielen anderen krankheiten bleibt
die größe der möglichen dunkelziffer
unbekannt experten sprechen von einer
weiteren beängstigenden zahl latent mit
tuberkulose infiziert also infiziert
aber nicht erkrankt sind rund ein
drittel aller menschen jede sekunde wird
ein mensch infiziert
und was noch schlimmer ist es gibt
keinen impfstoff gegen die tuberkulose
dass tuberkulose so gefährlich ist bzw
geworden ist erklärt unter anderem auch
die art der übertragung die tröpfchen
übertragen also einmal das gegenüber an
genießt und schon könnte der erreger
übertragen worden sein
anders als der hiv erreger kann der
tuberkulose-erreger uns überall und vor
allem längere zeit auf lauern denn die
verschiedenen arten des mycobacterium
tuberculosis überleben mehrere stunden
lang in der luft und bleiben damit
gefährlich gefährlich ist der erreger
allerdings nicht immer mit einem
intakten immunsystem kann der eigene
körper den erreger davon abhalten die
krankheit auszulösen kann das eigene
abwehrsystem allerdings nicht
ausreichend schutz bieten merken
betroffene das leider auch noch sehr
spät medizin professor doktor rendel
reeves
zitat es steht außer frage dass ich
lieber wegen hepatitis c oder hiv
behandlung wäre als mir dubai kuriose
zuzuziehen zitat ende
das macht einen nicht gerade hoffnung
tuberkulose bakterien lassen sich
heutzutage oft in der lungen jeder
husten leichtes immer stärker werdendes
fieber und schweißausbrüche können die
folgen sein
im weiteren krankheitsverlauf kommt es
häufig zu blutigen husten über den
blutkreislauf verteilen sich die
bakterien weiter im ganzen körper eine
infektion bei der nahezu alle organe
befallen sind nennt man dann milliarde
bercow lose begeben sie erkrankte nicht
schnell in ärztliche behandlung kann das
tödlich sein allerdings es gibt wirksame
medikamente gegen tuberkulose damit sind
ja beim nächsten problem die immer
häufiger vorkommenden
antibiotikaresistenzen erschweren die
medikamentöse behandlung enorm stoffe
wie sony az rifampicin ethanol und pyhra
ziehen mit die kommen in der meys sechs
monate dauernden und oft lange
stationären therapie zum einsatz sind
erkrankte mit dagegen resistenten
erregern infiziert kann schon nicht mehr
so gut geholfen werden also wieder mal
ganz klar nicht bei jeder kleinigkeit
direkt um ein antibiotikum betteln das
kann sich später als tödliche
herausstellen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation hat vor
einiger zeit einen weltweiten
aktionsplan gegen die antibiotika
resistenzen abgesegnet wie lange es
dauern wird bis wir dieses problem als
menschheit in den griff bekommen wer
weiß es klar ist dass der sondergesandte
der vereinten nationen ein brisantes
gesundheits thema angesprochen hat und
ja wie könntet ihr euch eine
verbesserung der weltweiten tuberkulose
situation vorstellen wer von euch hat
die tuberkulose als so dramatische
krankheit auf dem schirm und konnten wir
mit diesem video die brisanz ein wenig
klar machen also diskutiert es in den
kommentaren wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten video wieder ich freue mich
über jedes abo ist kostenlos nicht
vergessen und verpasst nicht das nächste
video bis dann bleibt dran